很多人都曾因为不懂得选股而惨赔
而美国投资冠军们却总是选到涨最多的股票
这些投资冠军最重视的选股指标叫做相对强度
这个指标也能看出机构投资者
有没有非常积极的买入一档股票
川哥经常有粉丝分享用相对强度选出来的标的
当中大多数后来都大涨
而且有时我事后才发现
原来我和投资冠军Mark刚好选了同一档股票
而且在同一天买入
那我是如何做到的呢?
这支影片会教大家如何用相对强度选到下一个周期的超级强势股
首先会教相对强度的定义和原理
然后会讲解选股的两个最佳时机
第三部分会教如何用免费工具看出股票的相对强度
春哥鼓励大家把影片看到最后
因为最后一部分会提醒使用相对强度的常见错误和解决方法
确保大家能完全掌握这个选股指标
不会用错
相对强度的英文是relative strength,简称RS
但注意RS和另一个超买超卖的指标RSI不一样
相对强度是指一档股票相对大盘指数的表现
当一档股票的表现相对大盘指数要好时
这档股票就展现了高相对强度,反之一然
例如在牛市中,涨得比大盘指数多的股票
和在熊市中,跌得比大盘指数少的股票
都是展现了高相对强度
那为什么选股要选高相对强度的股票呢?
接下来会从历史大数据、基本面和供需这三个角度来解释
塞奥股市这本书用历史大数据找出最重要的选股指标
作者研究了过去60年间每个周期涨最多的股票
并总结出它们在大涨前都有什么共通点
他发现这些表现最优异的股票在大涨前
表现就已经比大盘指数和90%的股票要好
所以历史的大数据告诉我们
如果想选到下个周期的超级强势股
就要聚焦在股价表现明显比大盘好的股票
夏澳股市的研究也印证了股市中强者横强这句话
接下来从基本面和供需的角度来解释
机构投资者喜欢选基本面将来会持续改善的企业
这些企业的特点包括收入持续上升
利润增长超预期
或推出新的产品等等
由于机构投资者预期这些企业的盈利能力
会在未来一个周期持续上升
所以他们会想大量买入这些企业的股票
而机构投资者的资金规模非常大
他们需要在大量买货之余
避免在短期内就把股价推到太高或太明显
不然他们买货的平均成本也会变高
他们通常需要分开几个礼拜
甚至几个月来累积筹码
就是因为机构投资者在持续大量买入某些股票
所以我们才会见到有些股票表现比大盘指数好
像是在熊市时跌得比大盘少
和在牛市时涨得比大盘多
换句话说
股价展现高相对强度
就是机构投资者大量买入股票
而留下的足迹之一
同时也代表市场对这档股票的需求非常大
需求大就容易推升股价长期上涨和跑赢大势
这里再补充三届美国投资冠军
David Ryan的选股心得
他认为虽然用基本面选股非常重要
但是他更看重股票的相对强度
因为股价表现和相对强度
往往会在企业公布财报前
就领先有反应
第二部分
会将用相对强度来选股的两个最佳时机
也会示范如何在没有指标的情况下
用最纯粹的技术分析
看出股票的相对强度
和机构投资者大量买货的痕迹
这样有助大家透彻的理解相对强度
到第三部分
学用指标工具
才会事半功倍
第一个选股时机
是在大盘指数持续下跌时
我们可以多留意跌的最少
最抗跌的股票大盘进入修正就是最容易看出个股相对强度的时候因为超过70%的股票都会跟着大盘一起下跌抗跌的股票就会变得非常明显和容易辨识
一旦大盘指数止跌
这些抗跌的股票就会变成下个周期的超级尝试股
虽然大盘持续下跌可能让新手不想关注股市
但专业投资者反而会利用这个选股最佳时机
找出下个周期的潜力股
我会用08年金融海啸熊市和2020年疫情熊市作为例子
虽然08年金融海啸是近20年来最大型的熊市
但是有一档股票几乎没怎么跌过
它就是Netflix
要知道2009年还是很多人在租DVD的时代
但Netflix新推出的订阅制串流媒体
正悄悄颠覆传统DVD租借这个行业
当时Netflix已经非常有潜力
基本面增长强劲
但是有注意到它的投资者却非常少
毕竟当时大多数人都不熟悉串流媒体
而如果我们懂得用相对强度的概念来选股
就能帮助我们早在09年
就选到Netflix这档超级潜力股
接下来会详细解释给大家听如何做到
我们来对比一下大盘指数和Netflix在08、09年的走势
上面是标普500指数的周线图
下面是Netflix的周线图
标普500指数当时处于熊市
长期持续下跌
而且呈现一浪比一浪低的空头走势
当时大多数股票都跟着大盘一起下跌
而在标普不断创新低期间
Netflix不仅没有跟随大盘指数下跌
股价还呈现一浪比一浪高的多头走势
甚至涨了一倍多
也就是说
Netflix当时的表现明显比大盘指数好
展现了非常惊人的相对强度
可能是因为未来的基本面增长非常可观
才会吸引机构投资者的大量买盘
后来大盘指数结束熊市修正
Netflix真的变成超级强势股
两年内就涨了超过500%
这次熊市表现抗跌的股票
还有Booking.com和Apple
随后股价也是大涨
甚至翻倍
现在回头看
大人知道当时Apple的iPhone开始流行
iPhone准备颠覆传统手机行业
Booking.com准备颠覆跟旅行社旅游的传统
但在08、09年当下
又有多少人真的能选到这两档股票呢
而如果我们懂得在大盘持续下跌时找出抗跌的股票
就能在09年就已经关注到刚刚崛起的Netflix
Apple和Booking.com
大家猜猜看2020年疫情熊市会选出什么股票
上面是标普500指数的日线图
当时标普在一个月内就修正了35%
几乎所有股票都大跌
但是有一档股票没怎么跟大盘下跌
它就是Zoom Video
画面下面是Zoom的日线图
在大盘指数急跌35%期间
Zoom的股价虽然又大幅震荡的时候
但整个月下来不仅没跌
还能逆势小幅上涨
股价表现比大盘指数好很多
展现了极高的相对强度
那我们该怎样理解这样的价格行为呢?
其实就是在疫情爆发初期
有些做了研究的机构投资者
已经率先意识到Zoom会是疫情受惠股
它的盈利能力会因为疫情而迎来爆发性增长
是个非常好的投资标的
即使大盘在2020年3月还在大跌
但机构投资者的聪明前
已经率先买入Zoom这档股票
由于有大量买盘涌入
Zoom的股价才会表现抗跌和逆势上涨
后来大盘见底后
来自大盘的压力就消失了
Zoom的股价就开始飙涨
用了半年时间就涨了超过200%
跑赢大势非常多
第二个选股时机
就是当大盘止跌和刚刚开始反弹时
我们可以留意反弹最快最有利的股票
通常最快反弹到52周高点的股票会是前例股
我继续用2020年疫情股灾的例子
当时标普500指数在2月大跌这档叫做DocuSign的股票也跟随大盘一起修正一开始不是特别抗跌但注意这几天大盘还在跌它已经不跌了
DocuSign的相对强度开始变得明显
而后来标普只是开始小幅反弹
距离历史高点还非常远
但同期DocuSign只用了10个交易日
就已经反弹到52周高点附近
反弹比大盘指数更快更有利
展现了高相对强度
而随后Docusign用了半年时间就涨了超过200%
从基本面的角度来解释
由于Docusign是一家提供电子签名解决方案的企业
疫情使它的盈利能力迎来高增长
而高增长的股票就有机会吸引机构投资者的大量买盘
导致股价反弹非常快
展现高相对强度
那段期间同样反弹又快又有力的
还有卖健身器材的Peloton
做电商的Amazon
做串流媒体的Netflix
我们不难归纳出一个共同主题
就是机构投资者正在大量买入疫情受惠股
这些股票也真的在随后半年时间内大涨和跑赢大势
虽然当时我们的主观情绪可能非常担心疫情爆发和各国的封城
会很怕买股票
但相对强度能帮我们客观的选股和找出主题
引导我们找出机构投资者在大量买入的股票
多数也是基本面正在改善的股票
这样选股既客观又有效
第三部分会教如何在免费平台Trading View
设定相对强度指标
和示范我如何用这个工具
选到2024年暂时涨最多的大型股
如果你身边有电脑
也可以跟着这支影片一起设定
首先打开Trading View的网页
如果你不是很习惯看英文
可以按这里把界面换成中文
然后需要注册一个免费账号
才能使用这个平台的指标
再来这边点产品和超级图表
在左上角输入股票代号就可以打开走势图
然后在上面技术指标这一栏
搜索Relative Strength
也就是相对强度的英文
之后往下拉
选Trader Lion做的这个Relative Strength指标
可以点一下新号收藏起来
日后就可以更快找到了
这个指标还能用在台股,港股和马股市场
我会在后面讲解更多细节
为了方便大家看出相对强度
我会加入标普500指数的走势
按这边的加号再输入SPX
然后选这边三个点的符号
选设定
把样式改成K线
再把它移到上面的窗格
这条有时蓝色有时粉色的线就是相对强度线
代表这档股票相对大盘指数的表现
接下来会教四个选股技巧
第一个技巧就是我们希望见到各股相对强度线的长期趋势是往上
例如最近一年NVIDIA的相对强度线的长期趋势就是往上
而且一底比一底高
这样代表这档股票长期跑赢大盘
这才是最值得我们选的超级强势股
即使大盘在这几个月进入中期修正
NVIDIA仍能表现抗跌
相对强度线还能慢慢往上
到2024年初
NVIDIA发展了新的低风险买入点
我在这些位置买入
我的选股和买入思路
也有在会员内容实施更新
隔天
我也有在IG发贴文
告诉全体粉丝
我买入NVIDIA的思路
当下我也不知道交易结果
是获利还是停损
只是衡量过后
觉得能够做到大几率大赚
小几率小赔
所以就选了这档股票
和在这些位置买入
后来我发现
原来两届投资冠军Mark
刚好也选了同一档股票
而且在同一天买入
也算是验证了春哥的实力
相信大家也喜欢这样实时操作和没有事后论的教学内容
买入后NVIDIA连续涨了11个礼拜
不到三个月就接近翻了一倍
也是2024年暂时涨最多的股票之一
反面例子是2023年的Disney、PayPal和中概股很多新手会觉得选这些大型股就没问题可是他们的相对强度线的长期趋势是往下而且呈现一底比一底低的空头走势
也就是说股价长期表现比达盘差
学会看相对强度后
就会知道该在2023年避开这些跑输大势的股票
少赔很多冤枉钱
另外,我们希望在买股票前
确认相对强度线的短期趋势最好也是向上
代表股价最近期的表现也比大盘好
这个指标很贴心的加入了均线
来帮助我们快速看出相对强度线的短期趋势
中间橙色比较平滑这条线
就是21日加全移动平均线
当相对强度线在21日均线之上
代表相对强度处于短期上升趋势
是正面讯号
指标就会显示蓝色背景
当相对强度线在移动平均线之下
代表处于短期下降趋势
我们就会见到粉色背景
这样在视觉上就一目了然
加持在买股票前
先确认个股相对强度线的长期趋势是往上
而且最好处于短期上升趋势
也就是有蓝色背景
第二个技巧就是要选股价还没创新高
但相对强度线已经领先创新高的股票
因为这样代表机构投资者的买盘非常积极
使得股价表现明显比大盘指数好
而这个指标会用紫色点来表示相对强度线
领先股价创新高
例如2020年3月标普大跌的时候
由于Zoom的股价几乎没怎么跌
所以相对强度线是往上发展的
而且出现很多次紫色点
同期DocuSign, Peloton,Netflix,Amazon
这些疫情受惠股
也出现很多次紫色点
紫色点出现的次数越多
代表机构投资者买货的痕迹越明显
那我就会买得越有信心
我在最近一次大盘修正
就用这个方法选出了Uber这档股票
在这些位置买入
在我买入前
相对强度线已经领先股价创新高
出现两次紫色点
让我更有信心买入Uber
随后股价用了4个月就涨了超过60%
明显跑赢大势
第三
可以根据自己的需求
客制化相对强度指标
例如可以用在世界各地的股市
只需要点一下这边的齿轮来设定
例如做台股
记得把对比的大盘指数换成加权指数
做港股可以换成对比恒生指数
另外,如果你是做中长线的投资者
也可以把相对强度线的均线换成50日或者200日均线
这样相对强度线的趋势转变讯号就会减少
第四,可以用美国投资冠军Mark的八个选股准则
来缩小选股范围
先筛选出所有趋势良好的股票
再观察他们的相对强度
我会在下一支影片中
手把手教大家怎么设定这些准则
不过,选股也需要累积经验和用不少时间
如果担心因为经验不足而没能选对股票
或没时间选股
也欢迎大家试用春哥的会员实战辅助
我每个交易日都会分享自己的选股和潜在买入点
等于是大家可以和春哥对一下选股的功课
这样选股能力会进步的非常快
现在有7天免费试用
等于是无风险
我把试用连接放在影片下面的资讯栏
最后会提醒大家使用相对强度的常见错误
很多新手学会用相对强度来选股后
见到高相对强度的股票就买
但却忽略了有时股价能展现高相对强度
其实可能代表股价已经涨了一大段
有可能已经远离了底部区
例如NVIDIA在这个位置确实展现了高相对强度
但已经远离了底部区
在这里贸然买入的话
容易在大盘短期修正时就被洗盘震走
虽然懂得选股很重要
但必须要配合精准的买入点一起使用
像春哥就在这两天突破趋势线和底部时精准的买入
大家接下来可以看这支影片
开始学习如何精准的买在趋势转折点
才能做到长期大赚小赔